en Nigeria tres candidatos se perfilan
para reemplazar al presidente de
muhammadá dujari tras los presidenciales
celebradas ese sábado hablaremos de
ellos y del proceso electoral en el país
más poblado del continente africano se
espera que este proceso tome varios días
y el análisis es
director general de de
internacionalización o de
internalización en la puerta de África y
fundador de Denise option Nigeria
gracias a usted
Muchas gracias Ángela Buenos días un
saludo y Comencemos hablando de los
perfiles de los tres candidatos
principales volatinuo exgobernador de
lagos y quien representa al partido
gobernante a ti Cuba bobakar que se ha
presentado ya cinco veces y que es el
principal opositor estos dos candidatos
acusados de corrupción y después está el
tercero en juego que ese Peter Ovi que
se espera o Él espera romper este
bipartidismo que viene jugando desde el
final del régimen militar en 1999 y que
tiene una característica importante
cuenta con apoyo entre los jóvenes
Cuáles son las posibilidades de cada uno
de estos perfiles
Mari Pues empezamos con
epitorobi que es uno de los fuerzas más
potentes estas elecciones especialmente
porque había 10 millones de nigerianos
que han registrado justamente para esta
elección porque acabo de la economía de
Nigeria acabo del inseguridad y todo lo
que está pasando mucha gente 40 por
ciento de todo lo que ha registrado para
votar en esta elección son menos de 34
años y por eso
la popularidad de pitaurovino está allí
con los jóvenes bueno continuo que es
como has dicho tú fue exgobernador de
legos que es la economía más potente en
Nigeria tiene muchas delegaciones detrás
suya y con es no es popular
decirlo de una manera con los jóvenes y
a ti que fue vicepresidente en 1999
hasta 2000 hasta 2007 ha contestado fue
candida tura siempre en los elecciones
presidenciales pero hasta ahora no han
ganado nunca
y sin embargo llama la atención cuando
usted habla de Peter Ovi que que llama
la atención entre los jóvenes es que
tanto él como sus otros dos
contrincantes son candidatos muy
longevos Esta es una democracia que es
relativamente nueva digamos después del
final del régimen militar Y por qué no
surgen otras posibilidades Porque además
algunos de estos candidatos También
tienen pasado militar por supuesto
Sí sí Bueno es que la historia de los de
Liderazgo Nigeria está muy conectado con
el militar si ves todos los líderes de
Nigeria desde 1960 hasta ahora o sea el
guari fue ex líder militar en Nigeria en
1979 así que tenemos una historia de
líderes que siempre ha sido conectado
con peterrovi lo que pasa es que es
tener 60 60 años 10 años menos de los
dos de
y menos de eso se ve para los jóvenes
como alguien que no es parte de la
sistema no que es un poco separado que
tiene ideas muy progresivas
Especialmente con un población de que la
media de la deidad es de 18 años Así que
con una población 200 220 millones de
personas en Nigeria y en la medida de 18
años es importante para los jóvenes
tener alguien que les entienda en esta
manera Bueno y por qué esta elección es
vista como un termómetro en el
Continente hablemos de esto y de Por qué
podría ser un mensaje de estabilidad o
inestabilidad para África occidental
sí Nigeria es importante siempre no
cuando hablamos de África porque
primeramente es la democracia más grande
en África con
200 como ya he dicho la población 220
millones de personas y en este elección
93 millones que podía votar es muy
importante saber cómo acabará las
elecciones ahora mismo hay muchas
cuestiones con el cuerpo responsable
para las elecciones que es el einec
porque hay muchas problemas y fallos con
la tecnología y ahora en este momento en
que hemos hablando está
está los resultados en la bulla que es
el capital en Nigeria está está en vivo
Así que estamos viendo que no hay
correlación especialmente de los
partidos menores como el como en las de
Peter Robi con los resultados que está
diciendo en abulla Así es que es es una
es una estamos en un muy muy
incertidumbre para para Nigeria pero aún
como ya he dicho es la democracia más
grande en África y lo que pasa en
Nigeria ponía influenciar en el oeste
del este y el todo el África Bueno es un
poco inquietante efectivamente
Escuchar hablar tanto de estas
dificultades técnicas que retrasan los
resultados y quiero preguntarles si esto
retrasa o resta credibilidad a la
elección se llevó a cabo la votación
desde el día sábado ya estamos a lunes y
todavía no se sabe mucho Hasta las
últimas horas solo se hablaba de los
resultados en uno de los estados y ya la
gente tenía mucha preocupación para ir a
votar y había prometido que iba a dar
toda la estabilidad y toda la tecnología
para que justamente este escenario que
se está dando no ocurriera
si en este momento de 36 estados en
Nigeria solo ocho solo sabes los
resultados de 8 no bueno es importante
decir que en Lagos que es el
estado del tiempo no ganó el Peter obvio
Así que dice mucho de lo que está
pasando pero también como ya has dicho
tú Ángela
tiene muchas problemas porque creo que
no pensaba que iba a salir mucha gente
para votar y como que ha salido mucha
gente para votar la capacidad y la
tecnología que tenían no podía soportar
toda esta todo estos votantes que que ha
salido
ahora algo que llama la atención también
es que no ha sido necesaria una segunda
vuelta desde el retorno de la Democracia
Nigeria será esta la excepción usted
cómo ve digamos La balanza entre los dos
candidatos tradicionales y Peter Ovi que
se presenta como la renovación en estas
elecciones
si según esta tema una cosa que es muy
importante decir es la tema de
Estructura No political que el partido
de Peter Ovi es literalmente nueva
decían una manera porque no había
estructura no tiene senedores No tiene
gobernadores en ningún estado Así que no
tiene el poder que necesitas no para
ganar la presidencia en Nigeria los dos
partidos tradicionales de actitud
Perdona sí que tiene Así que este reto
es gigante para pitarobia Aunque si
podía conseguir la presidencia será un
reto muy grande para él para conseguir
todos los planes que tiene para la
nación bien y finalmente que se sabe de
las parlamentarias que fueron las otras
grandes apuestas que se hicieron este
sábado
muy interesante en abu ya hay un senador
que lleva 20 años ganando en el capital
pero hoy mismo con los resultados como
ya te he dicho el partido de Peter Ovi
la persona que está debajo del partido
laborista que es de Peter Ovi ganó en en
el capital Así que estamos viendo que
está cambiando muchas cosas o sea no no
hemos visto en esta manera pero está
cambiando muchas cosas en ese lado
también
y viene ya para ir cerrando este espacio
de entrevista quisiera preguntarle por
estos cambios que espera la ciudadanía
en los comicios entonces hay mucha
expectativa alrededor de estos tres
candidatos Y de lo que podría pasar
después de que se anuncia el resultado
Cuál es cuál es la expectativa económica
para un país como Nigeria por ejemplo
Bueno creo que no importa quien gane
Será muy difícil
opicerobic o tinuco porque tenemos un
desempleo de 33% tenemos bueno el
petróleo Nigeria ya no es un país del
petróleo porque no está funcionando para
nosotros
lo que lo que ganamos de petróleo no es
lo mismo que los
hace dos décadas por ejemplo Así que es
un reto gigante para cualquiera Y creo
que en unos cinco o diez años seguirá
muy despacio la economía nigeriana y lo
que estamos haciendo socialmente
especialmente en relación de la
inseguridad
pues es director general de
internalización en puerta de África y
fundador de New ruction Nigeria musa
gracias a usted por estar en directo a
América Muchas gracias Ángela también el
agradecimiento para nuestros
televidentes y les pedimos que se queden
con nosotros en solo segundos volvemos
con más noticias
[Música]